we learned from a very early age to make
our sense of self-worth conditional upon
some kind of external criteria which can
be judged by others because of this self
compassion becomes a challenge because
self compassion requires a natural
ability on your part to be able to deal
with your failures as well as success
with understanding acceptance and
kindness the problem I see with the
self-esteem movement particularly is
that self-esteem movement again in a
kind of place into this tendency to make
your sense of Worth conditional upon
what you achieve and and and inevitably
that involves comparison with others and
and you know and there's also a moral
problem there because in order to boost
your self-esteem sometimes you need to
put down others in your mind where self
compassion doesn't require any of that
what self compassion is suggesting is
that you should be able to do the same
thing that you normally do it to
something that you care towards yourself
and the beauty of that is that once you
have that kind of ability to relate to
your own situation situation with
kindness it creates a kind of a
reservoir of strength and resilience so
that you have planned to the draw firm
because otherwise if your compassion is
always other directed and you do not
take care of the your own needs and your
own well-being at some point this kind
of leads to compassion fatigue and even
in some cases when the relationship does
not work and when there is not enough
recognition from coming from the others
the recipient side you might even feel
betrayed and let down and used and
ultimately even feeling bitterness so
having a greater you know base of self
compassion really buffers against all of
this potentially and negative
consequences of being always too much
either focused